les causes principales du stress c'est
quoi
l'oseille
l'environnement
le travail à le couple le couple
d'accord donc voilà c'est les relations
humaines quoi de manière générale donc
Daniel est une femme peu stress
pourquoi elle seule
[Rires]
bien sûr
l'objet dans la vie c'est trouver un
équilibre et donc le stress survient
contre il y a cette perte d'équilibre
dans notre vie alors le stress en plus
ça peut avoir des conséquences néfastes
dans sa vie de tous les jours alors ça a
des conséquences physiques
c'est des conséquences psychologiques en
fait le stress est un élément
extrêmement intéressant quand il est
utilisé à toute petite dose avant vous
savez dans la nature
au moment des hommes préhistoriques pour
la survie dans le cas de la survie alors
pour pour Gims c'était il y a 50 il y
avait des chevaliers noirs et mais
l'électricité mais dans la réalité
c'était à ce moment là pour
effectivement on a dû oui mais voilà il
fait c'était tellement ridicule il y a
du avoir dans ces moments-là on avait
besoin de ce stress pour pouvoir
survivre puisque quand on stresse on a
deux mécanismes on attaque où on fuit
c'est le cerveau reptilien c'est le
cerveau originel qu'on a tous et qu'on
partage avec les animaux c'est vraiment
cette mécanisme de réaction et c'est
quand il vient il survient de manière
trop fréquente de manière chronique qui
commence à nous abîmer à abîmer notre
corps et abîmer notre esprit c'est un
problème de ça c'est un vrai problème de
santé et ça des conséquences sur le
modèle de santé français pas que ça
coûte en plus beaucoup d'argent ce
stress complètement ça provoque des
pathologies et ces pathologies on va les
soigner et et quand on les a soignés
quand on a comme on n'a pas éliminé les
éléments de stress les pathologies
reviennent alors comment est-ce qu'on
peut lutter contre le stress il y a des
conseils
principaux
on respire
alors oui respirer ça on respire tous
quand vous faites un peu de yoga vous
apercevez qu'il y a deux manières de
respirer on peut respirer par la bouche
et par le nez et ce qui déstresse
beaucoup c'est de respirer par le nez
tout en pensant à quelque chose
d'extrêmement agréable alors moi je le
fais en pensant à mon papa qui n'est
plus là et quand je pense à lui que je
respire ça me détend et ça me permet
d'aller un peu mieux donc on cherche à
un modèle on respire on cherche quelque
chose qui nous inspire et qui nous fait
du bien et on y pense tout en inspirant
par le nez en expirant par la bouche une
question bête si on a des problèmes de
respiration
comment on fait et bon on passe au
deuxième conseil ah bah tiens
en gros
alors on se fixe des limites ah alors
les limites dans dans quel de quelle
limite on parle
on essaie de faire en sorte de de
d'avoir une journée de se dire que dans
sa journée on va faire un syndrome de
choses et c'est pour faire ces choses là
on va se mettre on va mettre en place
une liste de choses à faire la to do
list et ça ça c'est un phénomène de
déstress très important puisqu'on fin de
journée on s'est dit mais tiens ma
journée a été remplie et puis j'ai fait
ce que je devais faire puisque quand je
regarde ma liste et en fait finalement
j'ai coché tout ce que je devais faire
dans la journée et ça c'est un élément
qui vous réassure et qui baisse le
niveau de stress ça vous est pas j'en
fais tous les jours les touristes mais
je coche rien c'est ça procrastine on
fait des listes de choses à faire donc
c'est à peu près la même chose c'est ça
c'est d'accord on pense à soi ça c'est
extrêmement important c'est d'arriver à
ce que dans la journée on puisse avoir
des moments pour soi de se dire voilà je
vais prendre 5 minutes qu'à moi parce
que j'ai envie de de lire un bouquin
enfin de lire quelques lieux quelques
pages d'un livre de boire en pleine
conscience ou simplement de contempler
de se dire de sortir enfin de se mettre
derrière la fenêtre et puis de regarder
le monde et de se dire ce moment il est
à moi juste à moi prendre le temps
prendre le temps et prendre le temps
pour soi donc le spa
les vacances un truc un truc truc de
riche quoi en fait
ce que ce que je prône là sinon on parle
là ça coûte pas beaucoup d'argent la
méditation ça c'est accessible à tout le
monde et effectivement ça permet de
respirer de s'occuper de soi et d'être
dans le moment présent la méditation ah
oui moi je me disais c'est génial c'est
un moment où on se recentre ce soir et
effectivement on pense à respirer on est
là on est présent on pense ni à ce qui
va se passer ni à ce qui s'est passé
parce que de toute façon on peut rien y
faire on est dans une espèce de
philosophie de stoïcisme et c'est
vachement intéressant c'est quoi ça le
truc
beaucoup de nouveaux m'ont aujourd'hui
on a inventé bulaire
on apprend des mots j'ai une petite
question juste est-ce que le temps
d'écran sur un téléphone c'est un
problème pour alors c'est le c'est le 9e
conseil parce qu'on est en train de dire
des frissons des forêts
encore un nouveau objet
[Rires]
on trouve du soutien c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est important qu'on sait pas
ce que c'est comme ça
toujours non mais par exemple vous êtes
pas très bricoleur vous avez besoin de
faire quelque chose à la maison ça vous
stresse parce que vous n'arrivez pas à
le faire le fait de demander de l'aide
ça vous permettre d'être moins stressé
d'arriver à le faire et de diminuer
votre niveau de stress et d'économiser
un ouvrier
alors est-ce qu'un M6 ça peut être un
soutien aller voir un psychiatre en
psychanalyste ou un psychologue est-ce
que ça peut être un soutien il faut il
faut en éprouver le besoin en fait c'est
ce qu'on appelle enfin en psychiatrie on
va appeler ça l'Insight l'Insee c'est
notre capacité à s'auto analyser à être
capable de dire j'ai besoin de quelque
chose donc à partir du moment on ressent
le besoin je crois que c'est extrêmement
intéressant la parole elle a une vertu
extrêmement agréable elle calme les gens
la parole parce que les le fait de
parler entre donc ça nous calme ça
baisse au niveau de stress le fait de se
toucher aussi c'est extrêmement
important quand vous avez quelqu'un et
que vous le touchez que vous lui parlez
ça calme son niveau de stress d'accord
les mecs ils vont ils vont tous voir un
petit par exemple parler à quelqu'un et
il trouve pas de d'autres soutien que le
docteur ou le shrin comme il l'appelle
oui mais on a des amis on a des
conjoints et donc ça peut être aussi
l'occasion on a des enfants ça peut être
l'occasion aussi de trouver
pas d'enfants donc elle est grave
pas besoin de les poser tout de suite il
faut peut-être aller le voir d'abord
alors si ça c'est intéressant on exprime
son amour ouais c'est important de dire
aux gens qu'on les aime alors ça
commence d'abord par se dire qu'on
s'aime à soi-même le fait de s'aimer soi
peut permettre d'aimer les autres si
vous aimez pas vous-même vous pouvez pas
aimer les autres donc il faut d'abord
s'aimer et se dire régulièrement que je
suis extrêmement heureux et content
d'être avec moi ah oui oui quand on m'a
exprime quoi voilà c'est excitant tout
ça je
extraordinaire mais c'est comme ça qu'il
peut aimer les autres et faire passer
cette énergie auprès des autres parce
qu'il est d'abord cette énergie pour
lui-même c'est extrêmement important on
perd cette habitude on on se perçoit
même on on on aimant les autres si on
sait pas d'abord aimer soi-même exprimer
son amour c'est dire ne pas avoir peur
de dire aux autres on les aime bien sûr
c'est extrêmement important ça alors je
vous aime en tout bien tout honneur oui
oui non mais si je vous aime ou on a
tous enfin des fois on a des membres on
se dit est-ce que des parents ont dit à
leurs enfants qu'ils étaient fiers d'eux
paramètres ça mais dire à quelqu'un
voilà ce que tu as fait je suis fier de
toi je trouve que c'est extrêmement
important et ça fait du bien à celui qui
le dit et ça fait du bien à celui qu'il
reçoit j'ai une question est-ce que
c'est pas mieux de dire à ses enfants tu
peux être fier de toi non je me suis
posé la question je sais pas ce qui est
mieux en fait ce qui est mieux c'est ce
que vous ressentez
j'en sais rien je sais pas répondre à la
question est-ce que je pense qu'il faut
non mais je pense qu'il faut dire les
deux c'est à la fois que je pense qu'il
faut être fier de il faut que eux soit
fier de même mais j'ai pas de il y a pas
de on est dans un domaine dans lequel il
y a pas de règles d'accord dans lequel
on va essayer de de de d'utiliser un
certain nombre de système pour
nous améliorer nous-mêmes améliorer
notre relation aux autres pour faire
diminuer notre niveau de stress alors on
dort mieux ça c'est un problème ça c'est
un vrai problème beaucoup beaucoup de
Français alors on dort mieux alors il
faut dormir en termes de défensive
alors une demi-heure par nuit par
exemple
je m'endors pas et je me réveille dès
que je m'endors je me réveille alors
qui les aime ça vous avez compris
c'est vrai que ouais lui dans son cas
c'est et puis se dire à lui-même qu'il
aime non quand il se regarde c'est pas
possible
alors plusieurs questions déjà sur le
sommeil
merci c'est ça c'est la question de fond
c'est de savoir déjà si vous n'avez pas
l'apnée du sommeil donc ça serait
intéressant d'aller chez un médecin pour
vous faire dépister parce que les
syndrome de la télé du sommeil vous non
seulement vous empêche de dormir
correctement vous me respirez pas et
vous oxygénez pas votre cerveau
correctement et le matin vous levez vous
êtes extrêmement fatigué d'accord donc
la première chose à faire c'est se poser
cette question là après chacun d'entre
nous nous sommes différents moi je suis
un grand bébé j'ai besoin de beaucoup de
sommeil voilà j'aime dormir
vous devez vous devez dormir en fonction
de ce dont vous avez besoin et j'ai une
question est-ce que dormir avec des
cachets c'est la même le même sommeil
que quand on dort sans cacher moi j'ai
plein d'amis qui ne peuvent plus dormir
sans cacher et vous envoie et vous en
pensez quoi
[Musique]
oui mais est-ce que c'est le même
sommeil
on n'a pas le même type de sommeil et on
n'a pas du tout le sommeil réparateur
dont on a besoin avec des cachets
simplement de temps en temps on est
obligé parce que plusieurs nuits
d'affilée s'endormir nous sommes des
animaux dans le qui avons besoin de
dormir pour nous régénérer donc on va
répondre aux besoins physiologiques mais
les éléments psychologiques sur liés au
sommeil à la qualité du sommeil on les a
pas avec les cachets et puis
effectivement comme si Jean-Pascal on a
après développé une dépendance
indépendante il y a plein de gens
justement franchement quand on est quand
même de sommeil qui rentrent justement
dans ce système de prendre des cachets
qui deviennent dépendants mais à un
moment donné c'est quoi la solution pour
réussir à sortir de ça
non mais c'est faire un diagnostic parce
que il y a un certain nombre de
pathologies qui provoquent des troubles
du sommeil la plus connue et la plus
fréquente c'est soit les troubles du
stress ou à la dépression donc en fait
sur un trou du sommeil qui serait lié à
un syndrome dépressif le la solution
c'est l'antidépresseur et c'est ce qui
va régler le problème de la dépression
qui va par définition régler le problème
du sommeil il y a le sommeil n'est qu'un
symptôme donc en fait si vous donnez
non non il y en a qui a une question il
y en a qui disent que pour bien dormir
faut dormir faut faire des cycles de 90
minutes est-ce que c'est vrai
sinon
il faut compter toutes les 90 minutes
pour s'endormir et que notre type quand
on se réveille ça passe 90 minutes non
je pense que non je pense que le les
cycles le la quantité de sommeil elle
est personnalisée pour chaque individu
tu as besoin d'un certain nombre
d'heures de sommeil et tu le vois très
bien c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment
où vous dormez pas assez le matin vous
vous levez vous n'êtes pas en forme
c'est ce qui fatigue pendant qu'on croit
dormir ce qui fatigue quand on voilà
c'est exactement ça c'est le défaut
d'oxygénation du cerveau qui fait que
quand on se réveille on a l'impression
de pas avoir dormi du tout alors que si
on mettait une caméra on voit dormir
sauf que vous chiez pas votre cerveau
donc vous receveillez extrêmement
fatigué conseil numéro 8 on bouge vous
allez remettre mais bon c'est
l'essentiel mais le fait de bouger alors
reviens à la technique de relaxation
parler madame c'est à dire que quand on
bouge on libère des endorphines et les
endorphines favorisent la relaxation
donc le fait de bouger nous aide à
réduire notre stress nous aide à
améliorer notre sommeil nous est à
éviter de perdre du poids enfin à éviter
de prendre du poids pardon et nous
permettre de mieux manger donc en fait
vous voyez que tout se tient moi on m'a
dit que ben voilà faire l'amour au moins
une fois par jour ça améliorerait
[Rires]
par jour vous êtes un bonobo
ça dépend de zéro ça dépend de Madame
surtout
Benjamin ou de Monsieur
ah pardon vous par exemple toujours pas
chez Jordan de luxe on va on va finir
les conseils c'est très intéressant
alors lui on a dit on bouge on fait du
sport alors je vais faut pas faire de
prosélytisme mais le sport c'est pas
forcément elle est à la salle comme un
âne c'est marcher rapidement
en numéro 9 on réduit les stimulations
parasites du cerveau alors parce que là
il y a des parasites pas cher
qu'est-ce que c'est que non en fait ce
que je voulais dire c'est que on réduit
tout ce qui va exciter notre cerveau
avant de dormir donc on le dit beaucoup
pour les enfants vous avez vu il y a une
étude qui est parue sur le temps d'écran
etc mais finalement on est soumis au
même type de parasites c'est-à-dire que
il faut qu'on ait un rituel pour aller
se coucher il vaut mieux lire un bon
bouquin plutôt que de regarder une série
sur Netflix juste avant de dormir parce
que on est stimulé et que notre cerveau
il a besoin d'avoir un temps calme avant
de pouvoir avoir le lâcher prise et de
s'endormir donc en fait c'est ça réduire
les simulations parasites donc le
téléphone la télévision les jeux
électroniques voilà il faut il faut se
donner un temps où arrête ça on se met
au lit et on se laisse le temps de
s'endormir on ne peut pas voilà on ne
peut pas un film devant la télé
on fait tout ça mais la plupart du temps
ont si on n'est pas dans son lit on va
se relever on n'est pas bien on va
chercher son lit on va chercher son
pyjama on va se mettre dans le lit on
est pas bien alors que c'est tellement
plus agréable d'arriver dans une chambre
dans le noir dire quelque part dans
bouquin et s'endormir honnêtement alors
surtout quand vous quand vous connaissez
la télé allumée vous en avez devant un
film et la nuit avance et vous vous
réveillez devant un autre programme et
parfois on a des surprises
le café avant de dormir c'est pas si
grave que ça alors théoriquement la
caféine pour agir il faut plusieurs
heures d'accord il y a des jours après
c'est la c'est chacun d'individu qui va
être plus ou moins sensible à la
stimulation il y a des gens qui peuvent
avoir du café à 20h et s'endormir à 21h
sans aucun souci et des gens qui vous
disent moi si après 16h je bois un café
je peux plus dormir
de la tisane du tilleul
afin d'oranger
le concept c'est de se dire il faut
prendre ce qui vous va bien et et ce qui
vous convient en fait c'est toujours ça
le truc c'est d'arriver dans quelque
chose dans lequel il y a pas de il y a
pas de stratégie voilà c'est sa routine
à soi si vous avez envie si ça vous a
fait du bien de prendre une tisane avant
d'aller dormir mais pas de souci prenez
la force personnelle voilà évitez la
théine évitez la caféine voilà mais et
mais la tisane pose aucun souci et
dernier conseil évidemment on mange ça
c'est une incidence
vous allez avoir un sujet tout à l'heure
sur le sur le foie et et on est ce qu'on
mange ah oui ouais
donc en fait finalement
quand on fait des conseils assez
classiques de dire manger cinq fruits et
légumes par jour
c'est pas complet enfin voilà c'est
c'est important de respecter ça parce
que il faut éviter de trop manger le
soir pour sursimer ce qui se passe et
quand vous mangez le l'entièreté de
votre sang va dans l'estomac pour
favoriser la digestion donc on n'est pas
forcément très bien donc il vaut mieux
manger léger le soir et dans un
fonctionnement dans lequel on mange des
choses qui sont saines pas trop gras pas
trop sucré pas trop salé
comme un porc je sais pas ce qu'il faut
en déduire
on est ce qu'on mange ça c'est important
vous vous Jordan je vous vois manger
beaucoup de filets aux fiches
c'est pas possible si je vois manger des
du poisson en bâtonnet c'est ça c'est ça
exactement
merci beaucoup docteur merci beaucoup